Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills, and I'm speaking to you from APA's Technology, Mind, and Society Conference in Washington. This is an interdisciplinary meeting aimed at assessing current efforts to understand and shape the interactions of human beings and technology for identifying priorities for future work, and for promoting exchange of ideas and collaboration among participants. David Friedman is the director of cars and product policy and analysis for consumers union, the policy arm of consumer reports that focuses on product testing and consumer safety. Mr. Friedman serves as a thought leader across consumer reports and leads consumers' unions' public policy and analytical efforts
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯，我正在华盛顿参加美国心理学会举办的“技术、思维与社会”会议。这是一场跨学科会议，旨在评估目前了解和塑造人类与技术互动关系的努力，确定未来工作的重点，并促进与会者之间的思想交流与合作。大卫·弗里德曼是消费者联盟（《消费者报告》的政策部门，专注于产品测试和消费者安全）汽车与产品政策及分析部门的主管。弗里德曼先生在《消费者报告》中担任思想领袖，并领导消费者联盟的公共政策和分析工作，
to ensure automobiles and other products are safe for consumers. to improve consumer options for energy efficiency and cleaner energy, and to guide other important initiatives. An engineer, he previously served as both deputy and acting administrator of the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration and was Deputy Assistant Secretary for the Office of Energy Efficiency and Renewable Energy at the U.S. Department of Energy. Mr. Friedman also worked for 12 years at the Union of Concerned Scientists
以确保汽车和其他产品对消费者是安全的，改善消费者的能源效率和清洁能源选择，并指导其他重要倡议。作为一名工程师，他曾担任美国国家公路交通安全管理局的副局长和代理局长，并曾任美国能源部能源效率和可再生能源办公室的副助理部长。弗里德曼先生还在忧思科学家联盟工作了12年，
as senior engineer, research director, and deputy director of their Clean Vehicles Program. Thanks for joining us today. Thank you. So I'd like to start by talking about self-driving cars. And my first question is whether Consumers Union has a position on the need for and feasibility of self-driving cars at this point. Well, we're really excited about the potential for cars that can drive themselves. I mean, just think of a world where it doesn't matter whether you, have a disability, what your age is, or what your driving capability is, you can have mobility
担任高级工程师、研究主任以及清洁车辆项目副主任。感谢您今天加入我们。谢谢。我想从自动驾驶汽车谈起。我的第一个问题是，消费者联盟目前对自动驾驶汽车的需求和可行性持什么立场？嗯，我们对自动驾驶汽车的潜力感到非常兴奋。我的意思是，试想一个世界，无论你是否有残疾、年龄多大或驾驶能力如何，你都能拥有移动能力，
and access all over your city or town. Plus, if you combine those self-driving cars with electric cars and car sharing, we could dramatically lower cost for consumers while increasing mobility and lowering emissions. So the potential is amazing, but that word potential is important. The reality is the technology of self-driving cars in many ways is that, best equivalent to a novice driver or a teen driver. There's a lot of work that still needs to be done. So are we ready psychologically for self-driving cars? I think that is a fantastic and really critical question because when I look at self-driving cars, one of the things that I think is important is to make sure we have, we design automation for humans instead of trying to design humans for
并能进入城市或城镇的各个角落。此外，如果将自动驾驶汽车与电动汽车和汽车共享结合起来，我们可以在提高移动性和降低排放的同时，大幅降低消费者的成本。所以潜力是惊人的，但“潜力”这个词很重要。现实情况是，自动驾驶汽车的技术在很多方面充其量相当于新手司机或青少年司机。还有很多工作需要完成。那么，我们在心理上准备好迎接自动驾驶汽车了吗？我认为这是一个非常棒且至关重要的问题，因为当我审视自动驾驶汽车时，我认为重要的一点是确保我们为人类设计自动化，而不是试图让
automation because we will fail at that latter task. Humans are. Humans. centered automation is going to be the key to success here, and that means understanding more about how people are going to interact with this technology. What are the pros and cons of self-driving cars? I mean, I think it cuts both ways. Well, when I think of self-driving cars, I kind of think about we have two possible futures with this technology. In one future, we have a utopia where we have better mobility. We effectively eliminate traffic crashes, we cut costs, and have a great convenience feature for consumers so they can get wherever they want to go whenever they want to go. That's the utopia
人类去适应自动化，因为我们无法完成后者。以人为本的自动化将是成功的关键，这意味着要更多地了解人们将如何与这项技术互动。自动驾驶汽车的利弊是什么？我的意思是，我认为这有利有弊。嗯，当我想到自动驾驶汽车时，我想到这项技术可能会带来两种未来。在一种未来中，我们拥有一个乌托邦，在那里我们有更好的移动性。我们有效地消除了交通事故，降低了成本，并为消费者提供了极大的便利，让他们可以随时随地去任何想去的地方。这就是乌托邦
situation. The dystopian world is where we have self-driving cars that aren't safe, put people at risk, that increase the amount we travel and increase the emissions we create and create a world where we're all basically locked into our cars instead of spending time with our family and friends. So you mentioned the possibility of fewer accidents, and of course there's been a lot of publicity around the accident that just happened in Arizona where the Uber hit a cyclist. What went wrong there?
的情况。反乌托邦的世界是，我们拥有不安全的自动驾驶汽车，使人们处于危险之中，增加了我们的出行量，增加了我们产生的排放，并创造了一个我们基本上被锁在车里，而不是与家人和朋友共度时光的世界。所以你提到了减少事故的可能性，当然，最近在亚利桑那州发生的优步撞死骑行者的事故引起了广泛关注。那里出了什么问题？
I mean, why didn't the car know that the cyclist was there? Well, you know, there's several investigations going on, so I always want to be careful not to prejudge. We have two federal agencies that are going to dive in and try to understand the details. What I've observed from the video associated with it is a couple of things. One, it looks like the system wasn't capable of stopping in time in approaching a pedestrian in the dark. That's shocking. I mean, when we think of self-driving cars, we think of a car that's going to be safer than a human driver.
我的意思是，为什么汽车没有发现骑行者在那里？嗯，你知道，目前有几项调查正在进行，所以我总是很谨慎，不想预先判断。有两个联邦机构将深入调查并试图了解细节。从相关的视频中，我观察到了几点。第一，看起来系统在黑暗中接近行人时无法及时停车。这令人震惊。我的意思是，当我们想到自动驾驶汽车时，我们想到的是一辆比人类司机更安全的汽车。
So that's one thing. It looks like the technology wasn't up to task. The second thing is they had a human in the, in the driver's seat who was supposed to be there to take over in case of an emergency. But the human was distracted. And what that tells me is something I think we all already know. Humans aren't very good at watching paint dry. I mean, that's the job of these folks is to try to pay close attention to everything that's
所以这是一点。看起来技术还没有达到要求。第二点是，他们在驾驶座上有一名人类，本应在紧急情况下接管车辆。但那个人分心了。这告诉我的事情，我想我们大家都已经知道了。人类并不擅长盯着枯燥的东西看。我的意思是，这些人的工作就是试图密切关注车内
going on around them in a car that's supposed to be able to drive itself. That is a very difficult task. These cars should have driver monitoring systems to make. sure that safety driver is actually paying attention. I would say the biggest thing that went wrong here though is fundamental human error in the design, testing, and rush to market of these self-driving cars. And yet we've been talking about self-driving cars for something like 50 years, right? So how are we rushing to market? So if you think about automation in cars, we've We've actually been increasingly automating cars for over 100 years actually.
周围发生的一切，而这辆车本应能够自动驾驶。这是一项非常艰巨的任务。这些车应该有驾驶员监控系统，以确保安全员确实在关注。不过，我认为这里出错的最主要原因是这些自动驾驶汽车在设计、测试和急于上市过程中的根本性人为错误。然而，我们谈论自动驾驶汽车已经有大约50年了，对吧？那么我们怎么会急于上市呢？如果你考虑汽车的自动化，实际上我们已经
I mean, originally you had to walk up to a car and literally crank the engine to get it started. And then we created starter motors. So from starter motors to self-driving cars, we've had basically an evolution of automation in our cars. But what's different now is that the computing power and sensors available to car companies and tech companies is light years ahead of where we're going to companies. we've been. And they're now trying to figure out how to apply that to cars. So why does that mean we're rushing things now? Well, the problem is there's so much money to be made from a world of
在过去100多年里不断地使汽车自动化。我的意思是，最初你必须走到车前，亲手摇动曲柄来启动引擎。然后我们发明了启动电机。所以从启动电机到自动驾驶汽车，我们的汽车基本上经历了一场自动化演变。但现在的不同之处在于，汽车公司和科技公司所拥有的计算能力和传感器比我们过去所拥有的领先了光年。他们现在正试图弄清楚如何将其应用于汽车。那么，为什么这意味着我们现在操之过急呢？嗯，问题在于，从
self-driving cars that companies appear to be rushing to test these vehicles on our roads and sell these vehicles on our roads before they have demonstrated and proven that they're actually safe to be on our roads. So what do you think ultimately is the role of the human being inside a self-driving car? Well, I think really the big question is both what is the role of the human inside the self-driving car, but also what is the role of the human being in the design, manufacture, and approach and governance of self-driving cars? I mean, hopefully in the long term, we'll get to a world where cars are truly smart enough
自动驾驶汽车的世界中可以赚到太多的钱，以至于公司似乎急于在我们的道路上测试这些车辆，并在证明它们在道路上确实安全之前就将其出售。那么你认为自动驾驶汽车内人类的最终角色是什么？嗯，我认为真正的大问题不仅是自动驾驶汽车内人类的角色，还有人类在自动驾驶汽车的设计、制造、方法和治理中的角色是什么？我的意思是，希望在长期内，我们能进入一个汽车真正足够智能
and capable of driving themselves. But we're only going to get there if we recognize that self-driving cars do not eliminate human error. All they do is shift the propensity and the likelihood of human error from the driver where it is today, to the people designing the vehicles, to the managers approving those designs, and to the corporate executives who are establishing the culture of that company. Are you going to make the error of putting profit over safety, or are you going to make the choice to put safety over profits when it comes to self-driving cars? And that's so many people try to say self-driving cars will eliminate human error. That's not the case.
且能够自动驾驶的世界。但我们只有认识到自动驾驶汽车并不能消除人为错误，才能达到那个目标。它们所做的只是将人为错误的倾向和可能性从今天的驾驶员身上，转移到设计车辆的人、批准这些设计的人以及建立公司文化的企业高管身上。当谈到自动驾驶汽车时，你是会犯将利润置于安全之上的错误，还是会做出将安全置于利润之上的选择？这就是为什么很多人试图说自动驾驶汽车将消除人为错误。事实并非如此。
Unless our robot overlords take over, humans will always be in loop. So here's a conundrum, a self-driving car that has to make a decision. Let's say that there are pedestrians in a crosswalk and the car can either hit the pedestrians or it can pull into oncoming traffic. So it has to decide effectively between whether you kill or maim pedestrians or kill or maim the people inside the car. How does it choose? Well, I mean, this is the classic trolley car problem that has been an ethical question
除非我们的机器人统治者接管一切，否则人类将永远处于循环之中。这里有一个难题，一辆自动驾驶汽车必须做出决定。假设人行横道上有行人，汽车要么撞向行人，要么驶入迎面而来的车流。所以它必须有效地在杀死或伤害行人，还是杀死或伤害车内人员之间做出选择。它该如何选择？嗯，我的意思是，这是经典的电车难题，只要人们一直在思考这个问题，它就一直是一个伦理问题，
for as long probably as people have been thinking about this. And let me answer it two ways. The first answer is we have no idea. Why? Because there are no standards or requirements or policies for ethics when it comes to self-driving cars. And in fact, at one point, the agency involved with overseeing auto safety, the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration, put out guidelines saying that car companies should be transparent about how they're going to approach these issues. Well, in the most recent administration, they eliminated ethics from the guidelines. So I'm very concerned that we don't know and we're not going to know for a long time how the car is going to make that decision. What should happen is the cars should be designed to never get in that situation in the first place. It's kind of like the Captain Kirk Kobayashi-Maru approach, you know, when given a difficult test, change the rules of the test. And that's what self-driving cars need to do, is we need to design them so that they're safe enough that they can avoid those tough situations. And then if they are in those tough situations, yes, ultimately there needs
可能已经存在很久了。让我从两个方面来回答。第一个答案是，我们不知道。为什么？因为在自动驾驶汽车方面，没有任何关于伦理的标准、要求或政策。事实上，有一次，负责监督汽车安全的机构——国家公路交通安全管理局——发布了指导方针，称汽车公司应该对其如何处理这些问题保持透明。嗯，在最近的政府中，他们从指导方针中删除了伦理内容。所以我非常担心，我们不知道，而且在很长一段时间内也不会知道汽车将如何做出那个决定。应该发生的是，汽车的设计应该从一开始就避免陷入那种境地。这有点像柯克船长的“小林丸”测试方法，你知道，当面对一个困难的测试时，改变测试规则。这就是自动驾驶汽车需要做的，我们需要设计它们，使它们足够安全，能够避免那些棘手的情况。然后，如果它们确实陷入了那些棘手的情况，是的，最终需要
to be some public agreement as to what moral and ethical standards are we going to apply to the design of those vehicles. And that gets back to my earlier point. Humans are always going to be in the loop when it comes to self-driving cars. So what do you see as the role of psychologists in the development of self-driving cars? To me, there's so many possible critical places. that I can see bringing psychology into the development of self-driving cars. I think first of all, it is understanding human error and helping people figure out where does human error come from and how you can minimize it. Because, as I said, yes, maybe you're ultimately, you'll get the human driver out of the loop. You'll still have human error throughout
达成某种公众共识，即我们将把什么样的道德和伦理标准应用于这些车辆的设计。这又回到了我之前的观点。当谈到自动驾驶汽车时，人类将永远处于循环之中。那么你认为心理学家在自动驾驶汽车的发展中扮演什么角色？对我来说，我可以看到将心理学引入自动驾驶汽车开发中有许多可能的关键点。我认为首先是理解人为错误，并帮助人们找出人为错误的来源以及如何将其最小化。因为，正如我所说，是的，也许你最终会让人类驾驶员脱离循环。但你仍然会在整个
the design and decision-making process. So how do you, how can psychologists help understand and corporate culture and designer culture and software coder culture such that you can influence that culture, help us change that culture to ensure that the proper steps are in place so that safety comes first. I think another critical role is realizing that there's also humans are going to be in the loop when it comes to pedestrians and cyclists. Even if tomorrow, every new car was a self-driving car, you'll still have people on the roads who are walking or biking. And even if every new car on the road was a self-driving car next year, you still have a legacy fleet of human-driven cars that are going to be on the road for
设计和决策过程中存在人为错误。那么，心理学家如何帮助理解企业文化、设计师文化和软件编码员文化，从而影响这种文化，帮助我们改变这种文化，以确保采取适当的措施，使安全第一。我认为另一个关键角色是意识到，当涉及到行人和骑行者时，人类也将处于循环之中。即使明天每一辆新车都是自动驾驶汽车，路上仍然会有步行或骑自行车的人。即使明年路上的每一辆新车都是自动驾驶汽车，你仍然拥有一个人类驾驶汽车的存量车队，它们将在路上行驶
10 to 15 years. So how do you deal with that mixed-use situation is really critical. Another key role is how do you do human-centered automation? How do you ensure that a car that has no driver can talk to a pedestrian or other cars? How do people think? How do people perceive that technology? And what kind of communication from that technology around its intents can help save lives? So the car can't just scream, hey, stupid, get out of the way? Exactly.
10到15年。所以如何处理这种混合使用的情况确实至关重要。另一个关键角色是如何实现以人为本的自动化？你如何确保一辆没有司机的汽车能够与行人或其他汽车交流？人们是如何思考的？人们如何感知这项技术？来自该技术的关于其意图的何种沟通可以帮助挽救生命？所以汽车不能只是尖叫：“嘿，笨蛋，让开！”？正是如此。
Or just think of if you're a pedestrian walking across the road, rocking across a crosswalk, what do you try to do? I try to lock eyes with the driver of those cars so that, A, I know they see me and I humanize myself as someone who shouldn't be run into. Exactly. And if they don't look at me, then I'm nervous and maybe I won't cross. Well, what if there's no human in there? How do I know that car is paying attention to me? So this whole concept of human-centered automation, both the design of the automation for the people inside the car, and the design of the automation for the people outside of the car, I think is a rich and critical area for the world of psychology to get better engaged.
或者试想一下，如果你是一个行人，走在路上，穿过人行横道，你会尝试做什么？我会尝试与那些车的司机进行眼神交流，这样，第一，我知道他们看到了我，我将自己人性化为一个不应该被撞到的人。正是如此。如果他们不看我，那么我会很紧张，也许我就不会过马路了。嗯，如果里面没有人呢？我怎么知道那辆车在关注我？所以我认为，这种以人为本自动化的概念，无论是为车内人员设计的自动化，还是为车外人员设计的自动化，都是心理学界可以更好地参与的一个丰富且关键的领域。
Last but not least, it's understanding how humans deal with risk. Think about it this way. How many fatalities in the United States do we tolerate when it comes to commercial airliners? The answer is zero. How many fatalities do we tolerate every single year when it comes to our cars? A lot. Around 40,000. In fact, in 2016, it was 37,461 lives lost.
最后但同样重要的是，了解人类如何处理风险。换个角度想。当谈到商业客机时，我们在美国容忍多少死亡人数？答案是零。当谈到我们的汽车时，我们每年容忍多少死亡人数？很多。大约4万。事实上，在2016年，有37,461人丧生。
It was a record year, a 14% increase over two previous years. And yet we tolerate that. Why? Is it because we tolerate our own error? We can see ourselves in the drivers who are driving drunk, who aren't wearing seatbelts, who are making all these critical errors, but we can't see ourselves in the pilot or the company responsible for the plane,
那是创纪录的一年，比前两年增加了14%。然而我们容忍了这一点。为什么？是因为我们容忍了我们自己的错误吗？我们可以在酒后驾车、不系安全带、犯下所有这些严重错误的人身上看到自己的影子，但我们无法在飞行员或对飞机负责的公司身上看到自己，
or is it a question of control? If I'm in control, I know I'm safe. I mean, I'm a safe driver. All of you are unsafe, but I am a safe driver. That is a very classic attitude, and it comes with some risks. But if someone else is in control, how does that alter our perception?
还是说这是一个控制权的问题？如果我在控制之中，我知道我是安全的。我的意思是，我是一个安全的司机。你们所有人都不安全，但我是一个安全的司机。这是一种非常典型的态度，并且伴随着一些风险。但如果别人在控制之中，这会如何改变我们的看法？
These are critical things we need to better understand, not so that we can manage people around the safety of these vehicles, but so that we can manage the safety of these vehicles around people. So some of what you just said raises in my mind the question of legal liability. So who is liable? Is it the car and the engineering, or is it the person who's sitting there ostensibly doing little to nothing? Well, and this brings up a couple of things.
这些是我们为了更好地理解而需要关注的关键点，不是为了让我们围绕这些车辆的安全性来管理人们，而是为了让我们围绕人们来管理这些车辆的安全性。所以你刚才说的一些话在我脑海中引发了法律责任的问题。那么谁负责？是汽车和工程，还是那个表面上几乎什么都不做的人？嗯，这引出了几件事。
First of all, I think in a world where the car truly drives itself and there's no human driver other than setting the destination, I think it should be pretty clear. It's the company who designed and operates the vehicle. But the world we're in right now, there are none of these true self-driving cars for sale today. The only cars we have are cars that can take over some of the driving functions, but not all of them. And in 2016, we had a case where someone was driving a Tesla vehicle with its autopilot system. They ignored the warnings over and over that they needed to be having their hands on the wheel. They ended up plowing into the side of an 18-wheeler because the car couldn't see it. I mean, imagine that.
首先，我认为在一个汽车真正自动驾驶，除了设定目的地外没有人类驾驶员的世界里，我认为应该很清楚。是设计和运营该车辆的公司。但我们现在所处的世界，今天没有任何真正的自动驾驶汽车在售。我们拥有的唯一汽车是能够接管部分驾驶功能，但不能接管全部功能的汽车。在2016年，我们有一个案例，有人驾驶特斯拉汽车，使用了其自动驾驶系统。他们一次又一次地忽视了需要将手放在方向盘上的警告。他们最终撞向了一辆18轮大货车的侧面，因为汽车没能看到它。我的意思是，想象一下。
The car couldn't see an 18-wheeler going broadside in front of it and so plowed right into it. I would say there's double fault there. And in fact, the National Transportation Safety Board, that's exactly what they said. They said, one, the driver bore fault because they ignored the warnings, but also the company bore fault because it was allowing this car to operate in a situation. It couldn't handle. It allowed the car to keep cruising down the road, even though the driver was ignoring it. it allowed the car to operate on a road where you could have an 18-wheeler crossing in front of it.
汽车没能看到一辆横在它面前的18轮大货车，所以直接撞了上去。我会说那里有双重过错。事实上，国家运输安全委员会正是这么说的。他们说，第一，驾驶员有过错，因为他们忽视了警告，但公司也有过错，因为它允许这辆车在它无法处理的情况下运行。它允许汽车继续在路上行驶，即使驾驶员忽视了它。它允许汽车在可能有一辆18轮大货车横穿其前方的道路上行驶。
So until cars can truly drive themselves, both the human and the humans behind the car are going to be responsible when these cars hurt and kill people. Any other aspects of self-driving cars that we haven't touched on that you want to talk to people about? Well, I would say one thing that's, I think, critical for folks to think about is what is the role of government within all of this? And the challenge we have right now is a lot of the effort is actually to get government out of the way. So you have Congress is working on a bill that would allow hundreds of thousands, if not millions, of self-driving cars to be sold or commercially used on our roads that could be. exempt from critical safety standards. You have an administration that is making clear that all guidance on self-driving cars is voluntary.
所以，在汽车能够真正自动驾驶之前，当这些汽车伤害和杀死人们时，人类和汽车背后的人类都将承担责任。还有其他我们没有涉及到的关于自动驾驶汽车的方面，你想和大家谈谈吗？嗯，我会说有一件事，我认为对人们来说思考是至关重要的，那就是政府在这一切中的角色是什么？我们现在面临的挑战是，很多努力实际上是为了让政府让路。所以你看到国会正在制定一项法案，允许成千上万，甚至数百万辆自动驾驶汽车在我们的道路上销售或商业使用，这些汽车可能被豁免于关键的安全标准。你有一个政府明确表示，所有关于自动驾驶汽车的指导方针都是自愿的。
This laissez-faire attitude, I fear, is going to end up delaying the technology. The excuse that folks give is it's about accelerating the technology. But as we start to see fatalities from self-driving cars, I think that poses a huge risk for consumer backlash. And if consumers think that this technology is unsafe, it's going to delay the technology by years or even decades, which means it's going to delay the potential to save lives by years or even decades. So that's one of my biggest concerns right now is there are no protections in place. And we need, in the current situation we have where government isn't stepping up,
这种自由放任的态度，我担心最终会延误这项技术。人们给出的借口是，这是为了加速技术发展。但当我们开始看到自动驾驶汽车造成的死亡时，我认为这会给消费者带来巨大的反弹风险。如果消费者认为这项技术是不安全的，它将使该技术推迟数年甚至数十年，这意味着它将使挽救生命的潜力推迟数年甚至数十年。所以这是我目前最大的担忧之一，因为没有任何保护措施到位。在政府没有采取行动的当前情况下，我们需要
We need companies to step up and put safety first, to share data making clear how safe their vehicles are, to not allow their vehicles to be operated outside of situations where they're safe, and to stop working to undermine existing consumer protections in Washington. Well, thank you very much, David Friedman, for joining us today. It's been very interesting. Thank you. I appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts such as APA Journal,
我们需要公司站出来，把安全放在第一位，分享数据以明确他们的车辆有多安全，不允许他们的车辆在不安全的情况下运行，并停止在华盛顿破坏现有的消费者保护措施。嗯，非常感谢大卫·弗里德曼今天加入我们。这非常有趣。谢谢。我很感激。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，例如《美国心理学会期刊》，
dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes, which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all our APA podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.com speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes and see more resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究的对话，以及讨论心理学实践的《进展笔记》。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的美国心理学会播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集，并查看关于我们讨论主题的更多资源。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，这是《心理学谈话》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。